good morning are you worried that the
lights we might have blackouts this
winter I'm very worried about our energy
security I think anyone who's been
following the situation would be worried
I'm also very worried about the fact
that people are struggling to pay their
energy bills right now and they're about
to face eye-watering hikes in mortgage
payments as well we've published
analysis this morning that shows that an
average mortgage holder who's coming off
a fixed term mortgage is facing an
average amount on their bills extra
amount of 500 pounds a month if you put
all these things together could be up to
900 parts of the country like London in
the Southeast how would you fix that the
government has got to reverse the mini
budget this is what has caused huge
instability in the markets it's meant
that mortgage products have been
withdrawn it's meant that mortgage
lenders have been pricing in higher
interest rates and the government this
week in Birmingham doubled down on this
by hinting at more unfunded tax rate tax
cuts to call them unless they reverse
the mini budget we're going to continue
to see this instability although I did
feature a mortgage lender earlier on our
mortgage broker I should say he says
we've sort of reached the Peak at the
moment and he expects that to fall we've
spoken in the last few days to a number
of mortgage lenders and also to the
house builders Federation and others
about what they expect to see they want
to see more stability they want to see a
calming of the markets and in order to
do that the government has got to come
forward and publish the impact of its
proposals and to explain how they would
pay for these billion pounds worth of
cuts to corporation tax and to cutting
the cost of shopping for tourists who
come to the UK billions of pounds spent
on that as well that's the quickest way
that the government could get stability
back into the markets and get certainty
back because otherwise what is going to
happen is that house builders property
developers are going to sit on land
rather than build it because people
can't get mortgages and there's no
Market that's going to worsen the
housing shortage push-up housing prices
and you could find a lot of families in
this country in negative equity you say
stabilize the markets I mean just
looking at the pound against the dollar
there it is stable now but it's it we've
seen a huge fall in the value of the
pound over the last few days but we've
also seen an increase in interest rates
and their forecasts to rise even further
and the problem in relation to mortgages
is mortgages rise ahead of that because
mortgage lenders will price that in at
the moment part of the reason that a lot
of mortgage products have been withdrawn
is because they don't know what rate to
price that in at because they don't know
if there's going to be further
instability caused by more unfunded
borrowing that's why we're calling on
the chancellor to reverse this decision
they have crashed the economy and poured
fuel on a global crisis and working
people are currently paying the price
um we know that the government is
helping as far as energy bills are
concerned should they help with mortgage
bills well there's a very very simple
way that the government could deal with
this and that's to reverse the unfunded
massive package of tax cuts largely
targeted on the wealthiest we think they
should go back to the drawing board and
start again we're calling on the
government to scrap these plans and
start again and next week when
Parliament returns that's what we and I
suspect many back bench story MBS who've
been voicing their concerns at this Tory
conference this week will be calling on
the government to do yeah but that no
you agree with the reversal of the
National Insurance and that's a big part
of the billions of pounds that it's
going to cost well we've opposed that in
Parliament we've voted against it over
and over again because we're we're the
only country in the middle of an
inflation crisis to be putting up taxes
on working people that just seems
completely the wrong set of priorities
we've opposed that separately we'll
continue to oppose it's not that then
what is it corporation tax well we've
we've we opposed the the cut
incorporation tax it seems to me that at
a time when you have to make some
difficult choices choosing to increase
taxes on working people and cut taxes on
the profits of big corporations that's a
government that is just out of touch and
has got completely the wrong set of
priorities so that's about 20 billion or
thereabouts it's not it's it's a drop in
the bucket really isn't it 17 billion
pounds is quite a lot of money
especially when you add to it they've
decided to cut stamp Duty which last
time the former Chancellor housing
market movement well last time the
chancellor Missy sunak
um did that during the covid pandemic it
pushed up house prices because sellers
priced that into the cost of housing and
it cut many more first-time buyers out
of the market so at the opposite effect
that was intended and actually made the
housing crisis worse for a lot of people
who were trying to get into the housing
ladder for the first time this is our
money it's a lot of money and people
haven't got a lot of it at the moment
the government has crashed the economy
working people are paying the price and
that's why we're calling on them to
reverse that decision
do you think emergency call operators
should go on strike I don't but neither
do they and I'm not going to sit here
and condemn emergency call handlers
who've been told that they've got to
choose between staying in a job that
they love and feeding their own families
I will condemn a government that has
crashed the economy and poured fuel on
the fire of rising inflation and caused
interest rates and housing costs arise
for millions of families across the
country and a company that's just given
huge pay Rises to its top brass but is
opening food banks for its own workers
in order to eat they need to pick up the
phone they need to help resolve this
crisis and next week I'll be in
Parliament with colleagues from across
the labor party putting pressure on the
government to get a grip on the economy
and reverse the damage that they've
caused we've seen the conservatives
don't look as United as potentially they
might be when it comes to strikes I mean
you you are not as United as you might
be on the front bench I mean the leader
has told you not to go on the picket
lines and you did I mean I think do that
again I think we're absolutely United
Kirsten has been absolutely clear that
our job is to get into Parliament and
solve this problem get into government
and handle the economy right and that is
exactly what we're focused on that's why
next week I will be in Parliament doing
my job so those emergency call handlers
can get back to work and do their own
I'll always listen to my constituents as
will care as will Angela as will every
member of Labor's front bench but we're
clear and the workforce are clear that
they need us some of the only people in
the country who've got the right to hold
this government to account and summon
them to the House of Commons to do so in
order to solve this crisis for working
people up and down the country but is it
right to defy the leader when he
specifically says don't do it I I
haven't divided the leader I kissed
armor and I from the day that he won
that leadership contest have been on the
same page about what needs to happen in
this country and what our role is to do
it we're going to go out and show that
we're not just an opposition to this
awful Tory government but we're an
alternative we're going to bring back
stability we're not going to put
unfunded huge borrowing cuts to people
and make working people pay the price
for Tory decisions and Tory failure
we've been out fighting for that for two
years and we've been out this last week
at our labor conference showing how we
would get growth back into the economy
by investing in all people and all
places in order to get our economy
working would you go back on the picket
line look I'll always listen to my
constituents but no no Matt but I want
to be absolutely clear about this my job
is to be in Parliament holding this
government no I understand but the
leader said don't go on the picket line
and you did I'm asking you would you do
it again look I'm not I'm not I'm not
you know I'm not going to be on a picket
line next week or in the coming weeks
I'm going to be in Parliament doing my
job and actually I've never gone out and
picketed because that is not my job I've
been a member of parliament now for 12
years I've always met with my
constituents I've always listened to
their concerns and when they go on a
picket line I know that they do it as a
last resort but that's their job my job
as their Member of Parliament has always
been to go out and fight for wider
changes that's what I've always done and
that's what I'll continue to do did he
speak to you about it you know I speak
to Keith Thurman all the time but we've
spoken about the issue about the strikes
about pay demands and about pay
negotiations and we are a hundred
percent on the same page about this that
we're not in government with nobody has
opened the books to us we can't
negotiate in and get involved in
individual disputes but what we can do
is go out and fight for the working
people in this country whether they're
emergency call handlers whether they're
ticket office staff whether they're
nurses who are balloting for strike
action for the first time in over a
hundred years this country is not
working for most people and that's down
to the Tory government who've crashed
our economy and are pouring fuel on the
fire we hear from the chancellor that
drastic action was necessary you know is
a roll of the dice some might say if it
comes off
they're going to win the next election I
mean look at what's happened in the last
couple of weeks within a day of the
chancellor announcing this budget we saw
interest rates expectations Rising by
almost a percentage point and have
continued to rise ever since we've seen
that priced into mortgages so that an
average family coming off a fixed term
mortgage is going to face more than 500
pounds more on their mortgage payments
at a time when food prices are going up
energy bills are going up all that
action on energy bills that was
announced that we supported by the
government just a few weeks ago is going
to be wiped out by the rise in mortgage
payments last time people were paying
this much on their mortgages as a
proportion of their income it sparked
one of the worst housing crises in
British history we can't afford more of
their story government they've got to
reverse these decisions we've got to get
stability back into the markets and
where are you on team Andy Burnham
suggestions that he should move back
into uh Westminster well it's up to Andy
what he decides to do next but he's a
great mate of mine he was my neighbor in
mp and Lee for years and years he's a
great Champion for greater Manchester
and he said the other day that he wants
to continue doing the job the action
said Never Say Never he said Never Say
Never And I think he's right to say
Never Say Never I mean look at what's
just happened in the last couple of
weeks in British politics things change
and things change fast but he is doing a
superb job as the mayor of Greater
Manchester cutting bus fares and helping
young people particularly be able to
move for work and study it's made a
massive difference to the lives of young
people in places like Wigan where buses
matter hugely he's got the right
priorities he's doing a great job and I
want to see him do it for a long time to
come